[Música]
qué es la energía les pregunto pensemos
un poquito al respecto a ver qué nos
ocurre obviamente es un concepto que
admite muchas definiciones desde luego
energía podría ser por ejemplo algo que
me dicen que tienen que pagar a fin de
mes ahora que les llegó la factura de la
luz energía también es lo que quizás no
sienten que tengan en suficiente
cantidad con todo lo que les queda por
hacer de acá a fin de año energía lo que
yo estoy recibiendo con estos mega rayos
láser de luz por ejemplo les cuento
muchos conceptos de luego todos válidos
lo importante es que la energía es en sí
algo muy presente en nuestra
cotidianidad y está tan presente de tal
manera que en la mayoría de las
ocasiones es algo que justamente pasa
desapercibido y esto en sí está
buenísimo porque es algo que da cuenta
de nuestra calidad de vida pero
fundamentalmente también les cuento que
hoy por hoy el ser humano en la
humanidad habita en nuestro planeta
desde luego y utilizó una cantidad de
recursos naturales y generó una
determinada cantidad de impacto
ambiental como si viviese en un planeta
y medio esto significa que el impacto
ambiental que actualmente estamos
generando sobre nuestro planeta es mayor
que la capacidad de
y de compensar que tiene nuestro hogar
mundial podríamos decir y como
consecuencia de estos numerosos
ecosistemas se degradan a lo largo y
ancho del globo continuamente como
tierra de cultivos mares ríos bosques
etcétera y esto desde luego que tiene
que ver con cualquiera de nuestras
actividades ya que no hay ninguna que no
impacte sobre el medio ambiente pero
fundamentalmente tiene que ver con la
energía que consumimos que a su vez es
provista en un 80% a partir de petróleo
gas y carbón combustibles fósiles no
renovables no compatibles con la salud
de nuestro medio ambiente y de las
personas hoy por hoy la humanidad está
enfrentando uno de los desafíos más
grandes que ha enfrentado su historia y
ese desafío se conoce como trilema
energético o un problema de tres patas
por un lado a partir de esta utilización
de ingentes cantidades de petróleo gas y
carbón
estamos desajustando el termostato
natural de la tierra a través de los
procesos por supuesto hoy ya muy
conocidos de cambio climático y
calentamiento global que si se continúan
por las próximas décadas
se sabe que los daños pueden ser
irreparables
sumado a esto para las próximas décadas
en los próximos 50 años producto del
crecimiento poblacional y del desarrollo
de la calidad de vida en los diferentes
países del mundo se espera que el
consumo energético de toda la humanidad
pueda llegar a ser un 50 por ciento
mayor
y se desconoce cuánto petróleo gas y
carbón queda por explotar por sacar del
suelo pero lo que sí se sabe es que son
combustibles finitos que algún día se
van a acabar y lo que se sabe aún más es
que como les vengo contando ya la escala
de actual los estamos utilizando hoy por
hoy es incompatible con la salud del
medio ambiente estamos embarcados en un
rumbo de vida in sustentable desde luego
sumado esto a su vez aún hoy existen
aproximadamente unos mil millones de
personas en el mundo que carecen de
acceso a fuentes de energía seguras y
confiables lo que dificulta enormemente
su potencial de desarrollo humano
imagínense ustedes cómo se sienten
cuando no tienen luz por al menos una
hora o como mucho un día bueno piensen
que son así todos los días de su vida
necesitamos entonces reemplazar tanto y
tan rápido como sea posible petróleo gas
y carbón por alternativas energéticas
que estén presentes en todo el mundo que
sean abunda abundantes que hagan
utilización de combustibles o fuentes de
energía locales y que por supuesto estén
de todos hoy por hoy por suerte la
humanidad ya conoce cómo aprovechar la
fuerza de los ríos y la fuerza de los
mares la fuerza del viento la
temperatura presente en las
profundidades de la tierra incluso la
energía de los residuos y si quisiéramos
charlar de la fuente principal de
energía de nuestro planeta bastaría con
que miremos hacia el cielo y hablemos de
energía solar y en materia de recurso
solar les cuento que aproximadamente
tenemos a nuestra disposición unas cinco
mil veces la demanda energética actual
de la humanidad lo que significa que hay
sol para rato y que se puede hacer de
todo y para todos esto por supuesto
amerita que siempre se diga que la
energía solar es la energía del mañana
que es lo que se viene y es muy cierto
sin lugar a dudas pero también es algo
que se viene viniendo desde hace décadas
de forma tal de que por ejemplo les
muestro acá la imagen publicitaria del
primer panel solar comercializado en la
historia de la humanidad año 1954
imagínense si desde ese momento hasta
acá las energías solares o las técnicas
a solares no se han desarrollado
tremendamente y tal es así que hoy por
hoy paneles solares y termotanques
solares son alternativas muy costo
efectivas muy al alcance de muchos de
nuestros contextos domiciliarios
comerciales e industriales y a su vez el
rubro de la energía solar está
actualmente trabajando en el desarrollo
de aviones solares de barcos de
computadoras de carreteras de paneles
solares flexibles producibles a través
de compuestos orgánicos sintetiza bles a
partir de plantas de texas solares e
incluso de avión de autos que pueden
viajar a través del tiempo pero no esto
no todavía no pero lo cierto es que hoy
por hoy a partir de energía solar es muy
posible generar energía para millones de
familias tanto a través de grandes
parques o de instalaciones presentes en
cada uno de nuestros domicilios lo que
se conoce como energía distribuida tema
de otra charla en todo caso pero aún
para que esto sea posible
hace falta mucha difusión con respecto a
esos temas y mucha acción al nivel de
nosotros a nivel domiciliario con esta
idea en mente
hace algunos meses estuve junto a unos
amigos instalando un cargador solar
comunitario de celulares en la ciudad de
buenos aires específicamente en el
barrio la boca y la gente pasaba y
subían al respecto y cuando uno decía
bueno esto es un cargador solar de
celulares obviamente se ocupaban se
encantaban y cuando los invitadas a
cargar hacían más o menos algo así
tomaban el celular del bolsillo y lo
acercaban como como como con miedo al
cargador un poco pensando que fuera a
romper todo otro poco quizás idealizando
que fuera inalámbrico obviamente nadie
nace sabiendo esto no pasa por ahí pero
también esto es un cargador exactamente
convencional con la diferencia
fundamental desde luego que la energía
viene desde el sol esa es la principal
diferencia el resto es todo normal todo
igual algo domiciliario y esta anécdota
en sí lo que nos viene a decir es que
aún queda mucho por difundir antes de
que este tipo de tecnologías puedan
tener una máxima penetración por decirlo
de alguna manera en nuestro entramado
social obviamente tampoco uno va a
salvar el mundo por utilizar un cargador
solar de celulares pero lo que sí es
cierto es que acciones como estas y
sumadas a otras
colectivizadas absolutamente pueden
hacer la diferencia pensemos por ejemplo
en como somos a la mañana o como solemos
cargar a la mañana mejor dicho calentar
el agua que utilizamos luego en el café
o en el texto como es el procedimiento
llenamos la pava ponemos la paga en el
fuego
esperamos a que esté suficientemente
caliente luego llenamos la taza
disfrutamos de nuestro te o de nuestro
café desde el punto de vista de la
eficiencia energética palabra clave
desde luego los fundamentales que
hubiera sido mucho más eficiente la
cuestión si primero que nada vemos la
tasa luego volcamos la taza en la pava y
resina y calentaremos exactamente la
cantidad de agua que fuéramos luego a
utilizar y entre un caso y en el otro la
diferencia desde un 50 o un 75 por
ciento de ahorro esto es eficiencia
energética y consumo racional de la
energía acciones como éstas como por
ejemplo cambiar las luminarias de
nuestra casa por lamparitas leds o de
repente desenchufar a aquellos
electrodomésticos que tengan este
uso standby cómo hacer la tele o el
microondas o la videocasetera les pido
algo re moderno o por ejemplo dejar
enchufado el cargador de celular una vez
que uno ya cargó el celular y lo mismo
con la notebook desenchufar ese tipo de
consumos con estándar o consumo empírico
puede hacer más o menos al final del mes
que ahorramos un 5 o un 10 por ciento de
energía por ejemplo y si específicamente
desconectamos el router de internet ahí
por ejemplo podríamos ahorrar una
cantidad de electricidad equivalente a
la casi toda que necesitamos para
iluminar nuestra casa y basta con pensar
que el router internet gasta exactamente
lo mismo lo utilicen o no y cuando se
van a dormir o cuando están en sus casas
en una escuela a menos que dejen
descargando una película o un jueguito
cosa medio pirata no recomiendo esa
energía es algo absolutamente
desperdiciado y también por ejemplo
podríamos pensar en aislar puertas y
ventanas evitando infiltraciones y luego
ahorrar de esa manera en necesidades de
calefacción a la respiración dependiendo
del clima local o también por ejemplo
podríamos pensar en cambiar nuestro
termo tanque o calefón convencional por
uno moderno sin piloto y ahora
de esta manera varios meses de gas y
todos estos son consejos concretos que
si hoy al término de esta charla cada
uno de ustedes pudiera implementar al
menos uno de estos consejos en su hogar
los beneficios serían económicos y
absolutamente relevantes pero a su vez
si cada uno de ustedes pudiera
recomendar algunos de estos consejos a
algún amigo o algún familiar
los resultados no sólo serían relevantes
sino que también serían comunitarios y
también tendrían un impacto en el medio
ambiente sumamente positivo eficiencia
energética siempre se trata de repensar
nuestra cultura energética nuestra
relación con la energía
por supuesto no tendría ningún sentido
de repente dejar una lamparita aunque
sea led y super eficiente prendida en un
cuarto que ya no utilicemos o iluminar
nuestra casa además de iluminar la
ciudad de más porque en este caso
quedaríamos en un síndrome que les
defino yo hoy de términos muy muy
científicos conocidos como el síndrome
del dulce de leche light donde con algo
que tiene un bajo tenor energético uno
se emociona se engolosina termina
consumiendo de más y luego por supuesto
que el efecto es
eficiencia energética y consumo racional
de energía siempre siempre siempre está
vinculado con el replanteamiento de
nuestro vínculo de energía de nuestra
cultura y deporte consumimos lo que
consumimos no solo de aparatos
utilizamos para sino justamente para que
utilizamos esa energía y hasta acá hemos
charlado en sí de sustentabilidad de
impacto ambiental de energías renovables
de eficiencia energética y de mucho más
también espero que implementen estos
consejos en tu casa no me hagan enojar
pero no hemos respondido o quizás nos
quedó pendiente esta pregunta del inicio
de qué es la energía y más o menos vamos
viendo qué energía es en sí la capacidad
de generar calor de generar frío de
generar sonido de poner algo en
movimiento es decir es la capacidad de
cambiar algo algo aunque sea muy pequeño
en nuestro entorno y eso por suerte es
una capacidad que tenemos todos muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]